liberalism has very good intentions
it wants us to be free and over the
course of a few hundred years it builds
strong institutions that allow us to be
free so it both has a good intent and it
also has a rational way of going about
it the problem with liberalism is that
in constantly pushing freedom and in
placing so much weight upon reason as
the way that we reach conclusions it
slowly begins to erode the basis for its
own existence
i've just got back from italy and i've
managed to evade all of the cultural
stuff basically not been on twitter or
social media for a full week and i've
arrived back to find out that ted cruz
has been accused of
apologizing for nazi salutes at a
teacher's meeting and that rishi's
budget is racist or some other horse
[ __ ] so i've descended descended back
into the muck in the maya but you're
here with me so we're both going into it
today
it's a pleasure it's a pleasure why are
you interested in tradition
i'm interested in tradition because i'm
trying to find different ways to live
i think one of the problems with the
modern world is we're encouraged to live
in the present and we're encouraged to
live for ourselves and one of the great
things about tradition is it does the
complete opposite
it compels you to look backwards to root
your identity in the past rather than
the here and the now but it also compels
you to submit something to something
other than yourself
now that might all sound creepily
medieval and many people just hearing
that will think i don't want any of that
but that's what's so radical and
revolutionary about it and living in a
democratic consumer society as we do
one of the things you can choose the
past you look back to and you can choose
the things to submit to but either way
i'm just interested in living beyond the
here and the now and all those things
you've just described which are
so temporary and fleeting and very often
distracting
there's a blog post by a friend called
david perrell and he identified that the
lindy effect which is how long certain
ideas and pieces of art and books and
stuff stay around you can presume that
however long they've been around for
they're going to be around for that much
longer so the classics are the classics
for a reason 1984 has been around for
whatever 80 years or so now that may
continue we can expect for at least
another 80 years moving forward but he
identified that almost all of the
content that everybody consumes on a
daily basis has been produced within the
last 24 hours that it's the most unlindy
world that you could imagine
right yeah and isn't it extraordinary
how we have never had so much
information at our fingertips yet it
feels harder to learn and to retain
information i don't know about you but i
can in the course of a day learn
so much and by the end of it have
forgotten all of it so it's it's not
just a lot of what we're bombarded with
is nonsense or passing or fleeting it's
also our inability to retain it whereas
those big things those big central ideas
which partly because they've been around
for so long we slightly resist and kick
against because we think we must always
be doing something new but those big
ideas they stick
because they're powerful and they're
easy to remember and they're embedded in
the culture so you can't escape them is
it an allure of novelty do you think
that's why people always presume that
new is better
yeah it's definitely it's it's partly
human condition
uh the desire for something new but also
selfishness um and we all want to be the
creator of our own world we all want to
feel like we're writing our own story
that we're in power we're in command but
this is also a philosophy which has been
embedded in western culture since about
the 18th century i mean others would
argue it actually dates before then you
can you can go all the way back to
athens rome and see much of this as well
but certainly since the enlightenment
this this idea has been woven into us
that we must be skeptical that we must
seek the new that we must always doubt
existing knowledge we must always
question and challenge it
but i think in the last uh last sort of
20 or 30 years that's been uh we've
entered a period of hyper skepticism uh
hyper novelty um where partly because
it's the ability to do things new is at
our own personal fingertips uh we're
really encouraged to do that and we've
become allergic to roots we become
allergic to things which hold us back
and constrain us and limit our options
so we're producing a new kind of man
that that wants novelty all the time and
one result of that is that some of us
you ask the question the beginning why
am i interested in tradition some of us
are looking for the novelty of
consistency
i quite like now things which never
change so i like to go there are certain
galleries i like to go back to just to
see the same paintings one reason why
i'm drawn to church is because i go on a
sunday and i hear the same thing
unfortunately those institutions are
themselves attracted to novelty and feel
they're letting themselves down by not
embracing novelties so we get history
being rewritten we get churches
rethinking their liturgies but i think
they're wrong because actually many of
us crave the novelty of consistency
is it trite to say
that
letting go of the wisdom of the past and
presuming that we can recreate the
things that took thousands and thousands
of years of the smartest minds on the
planet to slowly culturally evolve and
whatever was left over definitely had
some wisdom in it that to me
seems like sort of flogging an old horse
like yes obviously that's the case the
fact that we've had so many different
iterations of societies whether that be
the on the individual level on the local
level regionally nationally globally
whatever whether it's culture
spirituality health
bonding family all of these different
topics to say that
to me seems really really obvious is it
or is it not
i i think it's striking how when people
do
uh attempt to
uh produce novelty they they produce
things which have been said before or
which everyone else is saying
so and i mean on both left and right so
whenever so many right-wing tracks and
so much right-wing thinking today i've
heard before and has been has been uh
said before particularly in the 19th
century in the way of industrialization
so many complaints we're not having
enough kids men are effeminate women
dominate society well these are terribly
old conservative complaints so i i think
i'm just really struck by how we keep
coming up with the same stuff and
likewise in this great era of cultural
novelty now
i'm really i'm really bored with it
because people just say the same thing
society is racist society is sexist
everything on tv goes over the same
subjects and yet with each iteration
we're told it's groundbreaking and you
wonder how much ground has actually been
left to break how many glass ceilings
there are yet to break through because
it just feels like we we went through
that ceiling 20 or 30 years ago
we're just doing it again for the thrill
of it you say that the west is at war
with its own history modern culture
encourages us to examine our ancestors
with skepticism even contempt why
why does it do that it partly it's an
inheritance of this 18th century
skepticism
the desire to start again which is uh
reflected in the french revolution and
all revolutions since which are this
this idea that
we have got this baggage hanging on us
and we need to get rid of that baggage
that if we did if human beings were
unencumbered by the past they would be
pure they would be noble savages who
would uh reach moral conclusions based
not upon anything that was
lumped onto them not not upon this sort
of rucksack put on their back full of
stones of old ideas and old sins but
instead they would reach good
conclusions through reason and debate so
there is there is a certain extent a
huge faith in human beings at the heart
of this the idea that we don't need the
past so i i think it's that but i uh
but there's also a crude of political
motivation
which is you mentioned 1984 if you want
to create a new future for people you
really have to start by erasing the past
you have to change their memory of the
past so they check you change their
thinking about the present and the
future
and in particular if you give people
this idea that the past in the past we
were thoroughly utterly evil
we were terribly wicked people then
obviously you need to start again
and once you say we need to start again
well that hands enormous political power
over to the people who said the past is
bad because we're left saying okay so
what's the future going to be what must
what what are we allowed to think what
can we be like and that's when you
empower the revolutionaries the cultural
revolutions to say okay this is what the
new society will look like in the future
now the experience every time this has
been done in the past the experience is
that you replicate uh the power
structures of the past in new forms uh
this is this is why uh michelle foucault
is is someone who conservative should
read uh because he points out that with
every revolution you change the power
structures but power doesn't go away
someone still wants to dominate so when
we create this new society freely from
the past you can bet your bottom dollar
there'll still be someone at the top and
someone at the bottom an oppressor and a
victim so it's a frustrating cycle of
behavior
but nonetheless i think i think that's
politically at the heart of it if you
could discredit the past then you can
say that the present order is broken
therefore we need a new one and that
leaves it open to intellectuals to write
the new order what are some of the
examples of previous revolutions that
have gone through a similar cycle
well the classic one is the french
revolution uh which starts out uh as an
attempt simply to reign in the king and
to produce a constitutional monarchy uh
but it very quickly uh it very quickly
moves beyond that and becomes a
revolutionary republic and then once
once you have torn up the old order in
the old constitution and particularly
once you have beheaded the king then
anything's possible and there was a
great desire there was a great fervor
for novelty in the news so french
society didn't just change its
constitution it instituted a 10-day week
it rewrote the calendar it abolished
slavery this is not all bad stuff
there's some good stuff that's done
that's one thing the american revolution
didn't do the french revolution did so
there was an attempt then to rebuild
society from the ground up uh the
consequence of that uh was not democracy
of course it was revolutionary
dictatorship uh once the constitution
had been written it was effectively
suspended uh it is true that in you got
rid of a lot of um
prejudices and you got rid of a lot of
uh authoritarianism from the past
but once constraints of ritual and
custom had gone as well you also made it
far easier to impose a tyranny
um so
that black
a tyranny when you get rid of the past
because uh
you do
over the course of centuries you do
accrue privileges but you also accrue
rights
and once you come along and you wipe the
slate clean you get rid of the
privileges but you also make it possible
to get rid of the rights
um in part because you change the
structure and the order of society in a
way that usually ends up empowering the
state and the new people who are in
control so for example
uh french society pre the french
revolution was incredibly decentralized
with a great deal of local governance
which would which would govern through
rituals and customs and patterns of
authority which have developed over
hundreds of years well the french
revolution doesn't want that it's about
creating a nation state so there's an
attempt to
harmonize the entire country to get it
to move and to think and to operate as
one so you could say
that's a a refreshing bold thing i mean
we as modernists we as children of the
modern world are encouraged to think in
terms of nation states and that would be
a liberating thing because the
individual is now part of a nation
rather than just some local area but of
course the consequence is you get rid of
local governments and you get rid of
local authorities and all the local
rights that had accrued around that so
in the course of trying to create a new
state you demolish much of that which
came before and this is very typically a
pattern in revolutionary societies uh
in that attempt to modernize you also
eradicate those things that over
hundreds of years gave people identity
and rights
why was notre dame an interesting
example speaking of the french
well i use notre dame in the book
because it was really the fire
of notre dame a few years ago which
which made me think i want to turn my
attention to this and
i mentioned it in the introduction
the history of notre dame is great
because it's an example of how tradition
does not appear overnight but evolves
and adapts and develops over time so
much of what you see of notre dame um
actually uh
most of it's very very old but in the in
the uh in the barak era it was subject
to a great deal of quite actually
unpleasant new decoration and then
during the french revolution uh when uh
the old religion was abolished and there
was a creation of a cult of supreme
being i mean literally the
revolutionaries couldn't imagine a world
without a supreme being because they
needed someone who would have the
authority with which to uh authority
which to invoke in order to impose a
moral order so having got rid of having
nationalized the church having carried
out a mini reformation and having
established a secular state the first
thing they decide they've got to do is
create a god create a supreme being and
so notre dame is then transformed into
this extraordinary pagan temple uh by
the end of the 1790s notre dame was
falling apart it was then restored in
the 19th century with the effect that
many of the gargoyles and many of the
decorations the church that you look at
and assume are centuries old are
actually part of a neo-gothic romantic
design to reclaim the medieval past so
modern notre dame is actually a 19th
century
throwback thursday yeah exactly exactly
um
and then a couple of years ago the roof
caught fire
and when it caught fire uh i noticed in
the reporting uh that many reporters
found it curious
that people fell to their knees and
prayed and there was a stunning headline
i think it was uh an ap
headline which said something like uh
taurus mecca notre dame also revered as
a place of worship
and that that just says where we've got
to in the 21st century that the primary
purpose of the church has been lost
that within
the very society that built notre dame
there are people who don't quite know
what notre dame is for or don't get it
and don't instinctively think that's a
place of worship instead it's a tourist
center and in the aftermath of the five
there were discussion about how to
rebuild notre dame and people came up
with lots of grotesque ideas modernist
nonsense
much of which hinged upon the idea that
notre dame should now belong to everyone
not just the religious that should be
opened up the entire public so you can
create a sectarian cathedral so you can
create a secular cathedral
um that's very interesting that that
shows where the culture has gone in much
of western europe that we've lost the
sense of sacred and much of what we deal
with nowadays in our culture which you
can see and woke as well is christianity
minus the eschatology it's a hangover of
christian culture but without god and
without a clear understanding of how
religions work it sort of deforms into a
new kind of liberal left madness yeah
you say that liberalism is the primary
villain here why is that
um
well liberalism effectively as the
political expression of the
enlightenment
and it's a primary villain um because
liberalism
has very good intentions
it wants us to be free
and over the course of a few hundred
years it builds strong intel strong
institutions that allow us to be free
so it both has a good intent and it also
has a rational way of going about it the
problem with liberalism is that in
constantly pushing freedom
and in placing so much weight upon
reason as the way that we reach
conclusions it slowly begins to erode
the basis for its own existence because
if you have too much freedom you
undermine freedom uh you know that the
man who eats too much who has the
freedom to eat too much and gives way to
that passion ends up becoming so
physically sick that he is unwell
and likewise when you have a political
culture which is so obsessed about
individual freedom uh so obsessed about
liberty that it becomes it increasingly
becomes impossible to think about the
corporate anymore or to operate
effectively as a society you begin to
actually undermine it and what's
interesting is that the
liberalism has sort of gone off the
tracks a bit
and it is now bled into identity
politics groups which are actually uh at
war with the very institutions
that liberalism help to build so the
effect is that those institutions are
either trashed or are captured by people
who don't really value what the
institution was created for
of which the starkest example is the
university always controversial i have
to say conservatives have hated them for
a very long time but the the university
has now been so captured and corrupted
by uh identity politics that
increasingly it isn't capable of doing
the things that liberals establish
universities for and wanted them to do
that is to test ideas it's now becoming
difficult to test ideas in them
yeah it's strange to think that human
nature is so inherently flawed
that we do need some constraints that
oddly constraints can give us a sense of
freedom and throwing everything out of
the window means that
you need to wake up on a morning and
choose what it is that you're going to
do how am i going to spend my day
am i going to lie in bed and
smoke weed and play xbox and order
deliveroo or am i going to fly to rome
or am i going to this is those are the
two options that i have in my life it's
smoke xbox
and um
yeah it's i i i sense this as well
because i think you're an only child as
am i
that right yes yeah that's correct yes
and i think that one of the maybe one of
the reasons why
you were quite attuned to some of these
things is the
extra sense of individualism and perhaps
atomization that comes with having a
very small family structure that if you
if you don't have these huge
big roots into the ground because it's
not just the sister and the brother it's
then the sisters partner and the
brothers partner and their kids and
their
in-laws and so on and so forth um
and yeah i get that sense sort of from
personal level as well looking back and
realizing that
you get to define
whatever it is that you want to do which
is liberating but also terrifying at the
same time and it means that you can make
a lot of mistakes if you don't have an
older brother that has made a ton of
mistakes before you and goes hang on tim
maybe maybe that thing because because i
tried i thought that thing was a good
idea and i wasted three years of my life
uh without that you end up having to
discover these mistakes for yourself and
a lot of what we need to do in life is
you can achieve an awful lot of success
by simply avoiding failure but the vast
majority of the things that you need to
stop doing it's just not [ __ ] up and
if you manage to get that right you've
probably gone pretty far but the freedom
yeah opens up those problems
yeah i i'm not i'm not giving away
anything here because i mentioned this
in the book so um but i had a difficult
relationship with my father
um
and
morality slash common sense is very
often transmitted and is transmitted
down the generations particularly
between fathers and sons
and when you have
when you just have no communication with
your father
you don't you have someone who's not
telling you how to behave or what to
expect so then your family becomes even
smaller um and i was fortunate enough
that my family stayed together but of
course other people have broken families
where that transmission between father
and son doesn't take place at all and
you can get to a point as an italian
thinker massimo rickelty i think his
name is uh who argues that actually
we've reached a point where because that
transmission has already been broken
you've now got people who didn't even
have the information to transmit it so
you have a generation which is
completely divorce divorced um through
several generations from that original
learning that fathers were supposed to
pass down so i i so so if you have a
difficult relationship with your father
it makes it all the harder but also yes
if you are an only child if you have a
small family as i do
you edge towards older age and you
become aware that what was once
liberating and freeing is is actually a
prison
because i could unless they invent
robots
that can look after us in old age i am
going to get to old age unmarried uh
without siblings and there's gonna be no
one to look after me right so we need to
be embedded
now i i for instance became a catholic
for religious and spiritual reasons but
it serves the utilitarian purpose as
well
i have something to do with my time i
have somewhere to go on a sunday if i am
old and alone i will be visited by the
priest
when i come to die i will be given the
last rights these you should not
you should not sign up to a tradition
purely in order that things will be done
for you that would be a very cynical way
of doing it but my point is that these
traditions serve human needs and over
hundreds of years they've worked out how
to look after the lonely and how to
provide a family for people who don't
have one yeah are you talking about
liberalism being part of the villainy
here but conservatives aren't fantastic
at retaining tradition either
no they're not no and part of the
problem is that the conservative party
with a capital c uh exists in order to
preserve whatever status quo it inherits
partly because it is the party of the
establishment so if the status quo is
liberalism and if the establishment are
all liberals then you're going to get a
conservative party that actually isn't
terribly conservative and that's what
we've had for about the last 20 years
the conservative party has really ate
new labor um i'm i like boris johnson
and i like where this government's going
i think this government might be a
change of direction but only because the
public has changed the status quo with
brexit this is the thing about trump and
brexit they came from the public saying
whatever the system is whatever this
order is we don't like it anymore so
clever conservatives are adapting to
reflect what the public thinks but in
that heart of hearts conservatives just
don't like rocking the boat and if the
order is liberal that's what they will
defend
i noticed that you spent a fair bit of
time researching genitalia
and circumcision
[Laughter]
i did it's funny how you can go down a
rabbit hole isn't it i did it
i i was drawn to it because it's the
it's the starkest example one can think
of
of an identity being imprinted upon a
child at birth and the most
controversial one now i'm talking of
course about male circumcision because i
think female circumcision is in a
different moral order although some of
the arguments against male circumcision
can apply to female circumcision
but fundamentally the idea that at birth
the child is marked
um as belonging to a tribe
and that that mark communicates not just
identity but also moral order
although it is physically done
by jews and muslims to
the boy it is also of course spiritually
done by christians to girls and boys
because they are marked through baptism
in a very similar way and of course
baptism of water is meant to replace at
the literal
literal circumcision of the flesh is
described as the circumcision of the
heart so i chose it because uh i wasn't
just being prairie and it it is the
starkest and most controversial example
of identity being printed at birth and i
understand why people have difficulty
with it but i also in researching it
came to understand why
it's so important to people why
well in some cases it's a historical
cultural thing
that because there were attempts to wipe
it out before some people feel a
responsibility to keep it going
because it lends them identity and
belonging
and also because in the jewish faith
there's a covenant with god uh it's more
than just identity
it also marks it it connects you to
abraham it connects you to the past the
history of the jewish people
and it and it conveys a moral order that
you are born to be a good jew you are
born to maintain this covenant
and therefore it is it is a stamp of
belonging and when you are part of a
people who there have been sincere
attempts to eradicate you
physically eradicate you keeping that
culture going is so much more important
and and you often find that among groups
that have been subject to attempt to
genocide that
the culture speaks for them and they
need to keep it going because it's proof
that they have survived against the odds
were there any other rituals or
interesting identity related branding
techniques that you notice during your
research
oh i find the uh the japanese the the
chinese uh ritual called zhao zhao
uh which is practiced after a baby is
born i was actually told about uh by
some friends who are of bangladeshi
descent so it seems to have spread
throughout east asia uh it's the idea
that shortly after birth
you lay down objects in front of the
child
and the child is encouraged to crawl
towards one of the objects and whichever
it picks up will tell it tells you what
their personality or what their chosen
career will be
and what i love about this is i was told
that the parents stack the game
so first of all you you the parents get
to decide which objects are laid down
there are certain traditional objects
you're supposed to put down but people
will put down things like stethoscope to
show doctor they put down calculator to
show accountant and if there's any risk
of the child crawling towards the wrong
thing like a makeup box or something
like that they will entice it towards
the towards the profession they wanted
to do
so although although in some ways that's
utterly cynical i think that speaks to
how much of our identity is is
pre-chosen
there are things that can overcome it
genetics and circumstances and
personality
but so much of the modern world is
wrapped up in this silly idea that we
invent ourselves we really don't i mean
just
you and i our language our gender the
color of our skin these things over
which we have absolutely no say
pre-predetermine a lot of what our lives
will be like and in march of these
rituals uh they're just
being honest about that
i had robert ploman behavioural
geneticist on the show a couple of
months ago and he has done the largest
twin studies in history so
10 thousand ish pairs of twins every
twin born between about 1992 and 1995 in
the uk has been contacted by him and
he's done
whether it's
adoptive parents whether it's twins and
he's teased apart nature and nurture as
tightly as you can and he ended up doing
a study to work out what difference the
choice of school makes
to your child's outcomes in terms of
education and also in terms of earning
once they get out and when you end up
controlling for the
area that people live in so the friend
groups that the children have outside of
school it's between one and two percent
so all of the move we're gonna change
postcodes we're going to pick up a move
because this
state school's got better ucas
performance or whatever all of that
stuff
oh [ __ ]
one percent is the difference and as he
says genes do not predetermine but they
do predispose that if you have a child
that's going to be a musician you can
force them into being a doctor and
you'll find them like twang in the
stethoscope
and
these
these um
the ways that we move through life so
perfect example for me i was a club
promoter for a very long time and i
still am but i love being a businessman
i didn't love being a party boy but it
took me forever to realize that but if i
look back at what i did when i was a kid
i talk too much and i listen to lots of
audiobooks that roll that forward by 20
30 years what's that it's a podcast so
that's you know we've sort of find our
way to the things that we're compelled
to do and the world and environment and
parents and tradition can sometimes
wrangle us away from that but we end up
creating our own and i think that
there's a certain level of anxiety that
comes with having to be self-created as
well that if your failures
are yours to bear and your successes are
yours to bear then your outcomes in life
are completely yours and
that it makes sense why people
um
why there's a
two
sided dagger to meritocracy but it's not
very nice to feel like if you are dealt
a bad hand in life or if you end up with
some poor luck which ends up occurring
that that was somehow your fault or it's
your job to get over it i'm not saying
the solution to that is a victimhood
mentality and quite the opposite but
it i can see why that would be
uncomfortable to hear
well i i think uh
i i think the modern uh
anxiety about genetics
gets to
it nicely touches upon some of those
contradictions within liberalism
because on the one hand uh
if if we are going to reach conclusions
based purely upon scientific method
then there is a there is a great deal of
evidence that famous genetics
so you think there would be a consensus
around genetics and genetic studies
on the other hand if you believe as we
believe and as i as a child of the
enlightenment and also as a christian uh
like to believe that people are the
authors of their own their own stories
and also that we shouldn't pre-judge
people on the basis of their parents so
there's there's a combination of
liberalism and christianity there uh
then genetics becomes really ethically
difficult to deal with uh because the
more information we have about someone
in advance that means we could make
judgments about them
um or we could see their lives as
somehow limited so you have attention
liberalism between
a weight of scientific evidence and the
actual ethical demands of liberalism
that we are the authors of our own story
so i i think that's that's one reason
why we have a great attention about it
and it's understandable um and then you
you get on top of that the modern
egalitarian impulse
that says that regardless of genetics or
regardless of even your own efforts we
ought to have a more equal outcome or if
we don't have an equal outcome then
that's possibly because of some bias or
prejudice or misfortune that we need to
correct so you begin to see how
liberalism keeps posing interesting
questions but then sort of denying
itself an answer
because each time you come towards a
possible answer uh liberalism comes up
with a new objection and a new question
and a new social
a new social problem we have to confront
none of this is a necessarily bad thing
this is all part of being human and i
welcome the moral inquiry but you can
see why it is that we have confusions
um over how important genetics is
because it's it it it goes to the heart
of the contradictions of liberalism what
use is nostalgia
it can be it can be a bad thing
obviously
uh although i think when we are
nostalgic we edit rather more than
people give credit for uh so we are very
rarely nostalgic about bad things so if
you take the example of the war there's
a great effort now to say we shouldn't
be nostalgic about the war and we should
certainly be skeptical and we should
present facts as they actually were but
very few people are nostalgic about the
bombing and the pain and the sacrifice
people are nostalgic about the sense of
coming together so in other words uh
nostalgia can be a way of writing a
moral story out of the past so i'm i'm
i'm upfront about nostalgia not being
necessarily exact history
rather it's an attempt to engage with
the past that pulls useful lessons out
of it
um and for that reason i think nostalgia
can actually serve a moral purpose yeah
it's an interesting one thinking about
the last whatever year 18 months or so
with statues being taken down and all
around florence and rome as i've spent
the last week there's some pretty
uncomfortable lessons and stories there
but they hold on to them and i'm not
sure that the same can be said for the
uk or the us holding on to its history
what's your thoughts on the danger of
deleting or unpersoning figures from
history and some of the statue related
debacles we've seen recently
i i am not unsympathetic partly because
some of those statues
you'll often find are quite modern so in
the case of the united states a great
number of civil war statues are not from
the civil war period or immediately
afterwards they're actually from the
1950s and 60s and they were established
in order uh to support segregation as it
was at the time so there are examples of
statues which actually we shouldn't be
nostalgic or rosy tinted rose tinted
about they actually were put up in order
to make a racial or political statement
plus some of those figures that were up
like colston in bristol were actually
pretty unpleasant and they were regarded
as unpleasant at the time they were
controversial at the time
and the idea that the public space is
unchanging and unchangeable i find
pretty strange there's no reason why why
you shouldn't change it
but
i object for several reasons one is a
democratic one i don't like the idea of
small groups of people saying we need to
change the public sphere without asking
others
and when they do that they very often
misunderstand what it is people like
about public places one of which is as
we mentioned at the beginning of the
novelty of consistency a lot of people
didn't know what those statues were of a
lot of people hadn't heard of edward
colston they just liked the statue
and the meaning of that statue can
change over time so a classic example is
the statue of baton powell was was
targeted well people aren't nostalgic
for bayton powell because they support
his views about empire or race um or his
his unusual approach towards
the raising of young men they're
nostalgic because they were in the
scouts themselves and that's what baton
power represents to them so i don't like
this undemocratic thing of rewriting
people's history
but i also think there's there's a risk
that you end up creating a very
simplistic binary approach to history
where you say there was a bad thing and
it got fixed and there's no in between
but the reality is is that history is a
process of people arguing and debating
getting things wrong changing their
minds et cetera et cetera and sometimes
it can be useful to have the entire
historical record on show
what are you going to do with the
founding fathers of the united states
some of whom own slaves some of whom
support a slave some who were against it
but didn't want to get rid of it some
just
stated well
some we don't have a great strong record
of their views on the subject what are
you going to do with people who didn't
oppose something that should have been
opposed because it's so morally awful so
you end up creating a a history that
jumps from oppression to martin luther
king and and the problem with that is
there's so much in between that's
interesting that tells you the story of
how we eventually got there through
trial and error so i think you could end
up creating quite an artificial history
if you just take down all the bad stuff
is there a potential that if you rely on
tradition or if you hold tradition up
too
highly as a virtue that we need to need
to keep a grasp of
that you're going to end up not having
to call people that did things mean
things bad things in the past to account
that
i'm not a fan of judging the actions of
people from yesterday by the standards
of today i think it's it's kind of
i don't know i it just logically i i
can't square that circle in my mind um
but i can also see the other side of the
fence that says we also need to bring
those people to account
yeah uh what i would say is that most
will many many traditions have changed
and have had a moral reckoning um and
engage morally with their past
a classic example is the catholic church
the catholic church is not does not
change doctrine
or document but it has changed its views
on many subjects in the way that does
things it has its views on slavery have
clearly developed and have changed and
it has held itself to account over that
it's doing it now slowly over child
abuse people act like it's not it is it
very much is
um and it will change culturally as a
consequence
so many traditions
do exactly that already
but of course if you take a blind
approach towards tradition if you choose
just simply to revere something without
interrogating it there is a risk that
you will end up uh perpetuating the
oppressions of the past of course
there's a risk of that but i
i think most sophisticated traditions
don't do that and are very
self-conscious of their limits at least
the ones that have survived generally
are what did you discover about the
traditional roles of men and women and
the family because that seems to be one
of the
real flash points at the moment
yes yes yes it is uh it it varies across
the world
and that's that's an important thing to
bear in mind one mustn't assume that
your tradition is the only way that
things are done and they're not i mean i
was fascinated to discover the existence
of um this very crudely put a third sex
in india called the hijra
who
are analogous to transgenderism but not
quite the same because it's a category
which can include gay men and feminine
men as well as as trans people and
eunuchs
um but that that's an example of how a
culture can have a completely different
attitude towards gender and sexuality to
the one that we have in the west plus
you also find that western attitudes
towards gender and sexuality have
changed significantly as well the 18th
century has a much different attitude
towards sexuality than the 19th does
and also there have been shifting
attitudes towards the role of of women
and their authority within the household
i was fascinated to discover that in the
wake of industrialization
as men moved to the city and they start
to have children out of wedlock the
catholic church begins to shift its
views away from the idea of men as the
moral head of the household to women as
the moral head of the household and the
church begins to promote uh things like
marriage counselling and that's when you
get the explosion of the federation of
the virgin mary and you get new ideals
of matriarchal leadership
so the really interesting thing is how
it has altered over time
um that said
uh until fairly recently uh in the west
at least there have there have still
been clear feminine and male archetypes
and those seem to be under some degree
of assault and i i know i understand why
and those archetypes can be deeply
oppressive if you obsess about men being
manly men well how do you categorize
people who are not madly men and gender
can end up becoming a performance which
is oppressive and restricting and no one
wants that it can be deeply mentally
unhealthy
nonetheless the idea of ideals or
archetypes i think is useful
and and the the attempt to throw them
out is very
dangerous and unhelpful so for instance
uh you you don't have to think that men
are better than women to say that men
can have moral virtues that are
masculine such as courage such as
strength
such as chivalry
and if you take away those virtues from
men knowing men as i do will just become
slobs
and not just slobs will probably become
women hating slobs as well because men
are like that
so i think that
that
the nature of masculine and feminine has
altered over time but what i think is
novel now is the attempt that you can
get rid of these things and that
actually being a man might actually be
some sort of original sin yeah without a
firm place to stand i see a lot of
the
masculine subcultures online whether
that be mgtow or red pill or black pill
or in cells or whatever
it's a lot of men trying to find a place
in the world
the ones for whom the traditional
positions in society or in a family
that those don't exist okay well what is
there for me now and this is i guess
one of the common uh excuses or reasons
that's given for why we have this we
have this collapse of religion there are
no more grand narratives to make us feel
like we are connected to those around us
we don't have ritual we don't have
anything sacred we're losing a sense of
or it's connection to the wider world
and dread about the fear of so on and so
forth all of this stuff um but you see
this replicated on a cultural level as
well outside of religion you see that
there are things that people need
to bind them together um
so it's it sounds like a lot of what
we're going over here is just explained
by chesterton's fence
is there
is there so where's the the nuance
beyond just wide-eyed longing for the
past and wanting tradition back
where's the nuance well first of all as
i've said uh we now live in a consumer
society so the joy is that you can
choose your tradition um
and i think you're going to get shopping
and i i'm seeing that a lot among my
friends i've got friends who've
converted to the orthodox church who've
become cops i've had friends who have
decided to leave london and go to the
countryside and to raise poultry and
things like that to live much closer
towards uh towards nature
so i i think uh people are finding their
own way and their own practical way of
making tradition work for their lives
for themselves i see it in the flowering
of literature of people like jordan
peterson
um
one of the striking things about
peterson is that he just tells us things
that 20 or 30 years ago were taken for
granted and they are received by people
as though they are novel um they're
really not but they're they're very
helpful to people
but i think also
i mean just to go back to what you said
there about
men and women
i think people need self-respect
and men in particular need self-respect
and i think there are certain rights
that are linked to gen to sex and gender
identity and we have a very rightly we
have a very strong idea of women's
rights and what women are owed and they
are owed those things respect
um space
and the right to advance and all that
but we've eroded what men are owed and i
think some of what people are looking
for is self-respect there is a sense
that men have the right to be
independent to stand on their own two
feet to have dignity to have a job with
purpose
and the loss of that identity is
actually the loss of a century's old
right
so i think people are searching for
things that used to in our culture be
taken for granted which do they now have
to rebuild on their own terms and their
own lives partly because the
institutions are not going to give it to
them why do you think they've been lost
for men
why do i think it's been lost
partly because of economic and social
change because of changing patterns of
work which doesn't favor uh men the loss
of blue collar jobs things like that
but also because the culture since the
1960s um
has increasingly become feminized and
that's
say that it's not a criticism of women
to say that it's just that there is a
a cultural sense uh that masculinity is
bad and femininity is good and you see
this constantly sold to you by
advertising consumerism and television
it's just a constant message being
drummed home to you and whenever you do
get a heroic man uh he is usually
conflicted and neurotic and troubled
uh i hate to bring this back to bond but
if you take the evolution of bond i
would accept that he was
a well-dressed neanderthal in the 1960s
i don't want men to be like bonds if
nothing else he's going to die of
alcohol poisoning and lung cancer
but equally what he has become now it's
so frustrating that he cannot be a hero
without being a psychological mess
who is redeemed through women and is is
redeemed through family i don't give
anything a way about the new film i
haven't seen it i've just read synopsis
i refuse to see it um but it just
frustrates me
that men cannot be allowed to succeed on
men's terms
yeah there's an interesting parallel
with children's tv that i think gets
brought up a lot as an example that if
you ever have a competition between the
boys and the girls the girls will always
be a little bit more cunning and perhaps
a bit more meek and the boys will try
and push the rules and be boisterous and
inevitably the girls because of their
quick wit they will always end up
winning and this kind of is a a very
consistent archetype that you see in
children's tv shows and um right
yeah i never thought of that
i'd never thought of the fact that you
can't just have
the classic hero the classic masculine
male hero anymore that he's able to save
today because of
hard work and temperance and virtue and
courage and fortitude and resilience and
grit and blah blah blah you can't have
that it has to be
a part of some
twisted
um
that needs to be the other side of the
coin to some deficiency that he has and
the deficiency
often yes is fixed by a woman it's the
difference between is the difference
between the adam west batman and the
contemporary batman we don't just keep
adam westbrook
right right okay but that's that okay
the the the overweight guy
[Laughter]
staggering his way through fist fights
with pow and blam i mean it's an
unrealistic city and actually it was
quite cap
and it was kitsch so actually it's far
more it's far more aware of the
limitations of gender identity that we
might give it credit but my point is
difference between a two-dimensional
morality in which courage wins the day
versus a contemporary morality in films
whereby they're reluctant to allow that
to succeed on its own terms it usually
does batman still generally wins but
there's usually some neurosis there's
someone who pays a price
there's some moral paradox there'll be a
woman who saves him no doubt and also
the other intriguing thing is that
increasingly the villains are the heroes
so you have suicide squad you have a
movie all about joker and
they are still presented in their flaws
and they're still presented as
psychopaths but i find a culture uh
which increasingly venerates bad guys
whereas in the past they were the bad
guys i find that really strange and it
speaks to something about the loss of
clear moral compass now
uh that we're we're concerned about the
victimhood of the joker
he's the joker he's the bad guy he's
supposed to be the bad guy that is i
mean
what role what role does culture have
here because obviously culture is how
would you say it's emergent right it
guess it can be manipulated by people
that are in powerful situations but
look at tiktok look at the ways that
brands that used to hold the power now
replicate what the creators that have
just been on the scene for six months to
so
what
is culture do you see it as a filtering
mechanism do you see it as some sort of
reflection is it a magnifier is it a
catalyst for what's going on what role
does culture play in either perpetuating
or eroding tradition
it's all of those things
a part of me cynically thinks it's
primarily about making money which it is
i remember i remember when i wrote a
book about hollywood some time ago
i spoke to someone who had tried to sell
an anti-war script to hollywood during
the iraq war and he had been rebuffed
and he came back to them and said i
assume i'm being rebuffed because i'm a
man of principle i'm anti-war new
hollywood studios you're you're you're
in bed with a pentagon and you love war
and they said oh no no it's just that
we've got dozens of anti-war movies in
the making we've just we're just bored
of them if you want to write us a pro
war movie we might be able to make it so
it's always been my view of hollywood
and entertainment i think it is just
terribly cynical it's also stuck in the
problem
of novelty we come back to the need
constantly to do something new and that
very often when you you have that need
you end up replicating yourself so when
you come to the end of marvel when
you've made not just every superman or
spider-man movie but you've made them
several times with a new cast you reach
a point where you have to say like what
the hell do we do that's new so you end
up doing things like elevating the
villains over the heroes or something
like that or i don't know you might make
spider-man
you might change his sexuality or
something like that
the irony being that because everyone
else has reached this point of cultural
exhaustion they're all doing the same
thing as well
so we have novelty that is reproduced
and replicated so i think it's partly
just the desire to make money
once tradition's been destroyed can it
ever be restored
oh yes because it's been done many times
before as we mentioned with notre dame a
building which has been collapsed which
is collapsing can be rebuilt and not
just rebuilt to look like the past but
also rebuilt using contemporary
techniques so you can have a beautiful
synthesis of the old and the new um and
we've seen traditions come and go and
they have
miraculously revived much of the
conversation that we're having now about
culture was being had in the late 19th
century and that was turned around
yeah yeah much of the much of the
concern about gender about identity um
about technology in particular um and
about how life was becoming too fast
there was too much information that
complaint was being made about the steam
train and about the newspaper um and
then you saw a sort of revival of spirit
um
in the
well i suppose did you really you saw
fascism and communism but you saw in
opposition to those things you saw a
revival of moral purpose so i do i do
absolutely think traditions can be
revived because it has been done i can
see how that would be done for a
an archaeological disaster
sorry an architectural disaster
but i don't know my concern is that
there's something whether it be the
frictionless access to information and
communication across the entire world
whether it be racing to the bottom of
the brain stem whether it be living
standards going to the point where
people on the whole don't have to
concern themselves with getting a sense
of purpose from their work and the slow
disintegration of the nuclear family and
blah blah blah blah blah i'm concerned
that you chop away at so many moorings
that potentially you can do so much
damage that it's a cul-de-sac you can
never drive back out of again
yes um my answer to that is partly it
would be uh
what it would be unchristian to despair
so i refuse to do that
um it's part because really that that's
a sinful attitude because you've got to
have faith and hope in the future and in
in the holy spirit and god's wisdom so i
i reject that on a sort of almost
theological basis um but i i also think
you've got to have faith in the strength
of traditions themselves that they they
are they have been tested by so many
things in the past plagues and wars and
fascism and communism and they have
endured because they've got good ideas
that speak to human need and those needs
don't go away i mean even if you have a
leisure society
there's still this need to be productive
there still is a need to fill your time
with something and that can be filled
with craftsmanship with artisanship
and the other point i'd make is that it
becomes different i agree with you
something has changed in our society
because so many institutions have
collapsed
information has been democratized there
is so much of it uh and the way our
brains actually work has altered in the
last 20 years but that simply means that
we then have to actively choose to step
outside of this new order and go and do
something else
and just in the course of writing this
book i had to read so many things i'd
never read before and it was like being
back at university and for a year there
almost was no tv no internet there was
just good old-fashioned books and not
only was it an intellectual feast and a
joy but i also physically felt better
you actually find that old forms of
living
they actually have a physiological
effect and i'm convinced that once
people i think lots of people almost
like getting bored of mcdonald's will
get bored of this lifestyle will look
back and they'll find waiting for them
this treasure trove of traditions and
customs and rituals to enjoy which have
been designed to meet these desires that
we have yeah i think that's certainly
something you're seeing at the moment do
you predict a how would you say
uh a tradition counterculture coming at
some point soon then
yeah i think it's happening i think it's
already happening it's happening within
religious circles that's happening
within the catholic church with the
revival of interest and things like
traditional rights so i can only speak
to those those those areas of life which
i know about myself um i but i i see it
taking place there and i see it in the
conversations that people are having
about culture
it's so fascinating that uh culture
seems to have trumped economics at a
point at a point at which we really
ought to be concerned about whether or
not we can keep the lights on
uh people are still tearing their hair
out over things like statues and that's
both a depressing thing a frustrating
thing but in some ways a good thing
because i think people have realized
that it's not all about material
questions that there are bigger cultural
and spiritual things that really matter
and possibly even a more important than
money
and the return of those fundamental
questions
i think shows that
the human species is is in the mood
to revive some things i hope that people
that resonate with that sort of a
message realize that they're not on
their own the number of guys and girls
that i've got i'm friends with that work
for me that i've podcasted with and i
keep in touch with
so many of them are yearning for this
same sort of thing perfect example
everybody out in austin who's just
bought a ranch which is
four units down from ryan holiday so
it's probably about 100 miles away from
it but it's only however many units down
and i was saying hey man i can't wait to
come out and visit you um
how are you spending your weekends what
what can we do should we go
wakeboarding or should we go and have
dinner and he said well actually man
like a lot of the time on a weekend we
spend building fences we put fences up
we hold the ground we do this sort of
stuff and my first reaction was dude
like tell me and i'm in tell me
and you think that's the most indigent
laborer the lowest of the low
sort of job
and i'm choosing to do that in my
leisure time
i'm choosing to go out of my way why
what is it that's compelling me that's
drawing me toward that sort of a
lifestyle
you need you need structure and purpose
um ultimately
there is
and i speak entirely for myself here
there is no point to life unless there
is a reason to die
there there is no point to your life
unless you have something to die for
that's how i feel i feel that strongly
and for most people it's their kids
most people it's their family well i
don't have that but i have a set of
other principles and philosophies and
beliefs for which i am prepared to die
and the strange thing is that makes life
more worth living and it makes it makes
life so much more colorful and enjoyable
knowing
that there is this thing beyond myself
that i am connected to which is my faith
um for which i i am prepared to go to
the wall
and
those parts of my life in which i didn't
have that uh were awful they just felt
pointless you're just you're just
getting by day by day and you accrue
tasks and responsibilities you recruit
a sense of responsibility that flows
from that philosophy
that means that
small things that if you didn't have
that philosophy would be pointless
actually are the most important thing
all right so i've reached the point when
i was young i wanted to be rich and
powerful like most people want to be
i now when i die hope people say he was
a nice person
that's the most important thing to me
not because i've given up
but because i've actually realized
that's the most important thing and that
that flows from my christian beliefs i
would much rather be remembered for the
one time i gave someone a lift than for
having been prime minister of great
britain or some crap like that which
ultimately doesn't matter so that that's
what comes from having purpose is a
well-ordered life in which the small
stuff actually gains new meaning
where should people find their meaning
let's say that somebody doesn't have
your faith where should they find it
just look for it and i i know you may
well not it may end up not being found
in religion uh i just i i just implore
people that's what i the one thing i
hope the book does is i implore people
to explore to explore
not just their own traditions and past
but other peoples as well
and they might find they might find
redemption in very surprising places
um but also one finds meaning in other
people too not everyone does i'm a
natural loner
but still
as i said
to be remembered fondly by people to be
appreciated by people is very important
so i think it's a combination of study
and learning and travel
but also
trying to do good for people so that
they appreciate you being around that's
a firmer place to stand when you think
about a lot of the
existential ills that people have it's
around the fact that
everything feels a bit hollow
yeah and a bit shallow
and kind of fragile
and a bit of a waste of time and
everyone kind of in the back of their
mind has this fear that what they're
doing
might just be a waste of time
and yeah i think that the the reason
that the family
is
i that's why it's so pernicious when you
think about potentially destroying
the family as a source of meaning or
saying that you don't need to
find find purpose and meaning within the
connections that you have around you in
your familial setting
you know you are
what's left for people to stand upon
once you do take that away if you've got
an increasingly secular society you have
one that bows at the altar of science
rather than religion
there's not a whole lot left and that's
why i think just the general
pointlessness of it all i'm just the
droid's
379 405 bleeping away in the background
doing things until i slowly cut myself
off to the grave like that's not that's
not that's not the story that we were
given right that's not the life that we
were [ __ ] promised and especially the
last the last week i've spent you know
walking through the streets of florence
or um vespering through the the hills of
tuscany which is obviously very
traditional that's bringing drinking red
wine because that's precisely what
michelangelo was doing and
just doing that and seeing
feeling much more connected seeing a
very different pace of life seeing a
much more religious place of life seeing
people that were really really connected
to their work and found great meaning in
their you know tour guides are a perfect
example of this for the two and a half
hours that you have that tour guide all
that that person is concerned with is
educating you on something that they
know inside out some guy that went to
university for four years to study
the city of florence and its history and
if you decide to ask him about dante
he's got two hours that he can do on
dante and if you ask him about
machiavelli he's got two hours that he
can do on machiavelli and you just think
like this is somebody who is connected
to a higher purpose they believe that
they are doing something that adds value
because i will remember the different
guys whether it was lorenzo or christian
or oscar the different people that took
me around different areas of their
country and would have pride in it and
had genuine connection when they spoke
about they spoke about we
we had this we had this challenge and we
came together this story about the mud
angels where there was this huge flood
in 1966 in florence and people from all
over the world came we were so thankful
for all of these people that were coming
towards and you think yes this is
connection and in those people you see
a sense of belonging and purpose and
meaning
and
yeah it's it doesn't surprise me that
that's the case and the other thing that
i was thinking
as i was reading your book
and as i was
traveling around jumping around italy it
seems paradoxical that
some people want to totally tear down
and reconstruct modern society and then
other people kind of just want nothing
to change but with both of them the
implication is that neither of them are
very happy with how things are going
right now that one's fearful of the
direction that we're going into and that
one kind of is trying to restrict the
changes
but neither groups actually that happy
with what's going on
no no and one criticism i have of that
that kind of conservatism you just
described is very often they are
patriots who don't like their country
uh which which i think is quite
unhealthy you have to accept that your
country has changed and will change and
changed in the past and it might
actually be part of what makes the
country good is its capacity to change
so i'm very wary of those sorts of
people but what what you described there
that connection to uh the community's
identity
um this is really what tradition is it's
the passing on it literally means the
passing on of something that's all it
really means which means you have a
relationship as an individual to what's
come before and also what's in the
future
which is a brilliant way of of rooting
yourself it's not just about you in this
moment not just about you on twitter or
you on youtube or
you having sex doing drugs and getting
the joy out of the moment
you're actually in you're actually
engaged with what's come thousands of
years before and you're concerned that
you will be able to contribute something
that will be passed on and people do
that genetically through family that's
what family is about
families have great mythologies about
their past they have great nostalgia
about their past and they pass those
stories on an example tradition is the
football game taking your son to a
football game you do it because your
father did it to you and you do it in
the hope that your son will someday
someday take his son so in that moment
you're not just in the moment of the joy
of the game but you're also uh you're
also situated in history a past and a
future you don't yet know and you do you
do get that sense in italian society
which i think is far more
self-confidently uh happy with its past
although you're also there in the city
of savannah roller and the bonfire of
the vanities
where there was an attempt uh during the
renaissance to eradicate uh classical
learning in the past so even even those
highly traditional societies still go
through these revolutionary moments yeah
there's revolutionaries all smattered
throughout history it's um
it's a strange one it really is i feel
like this is a conversation talking
about tradition is something that
continues to come up it's kind of like a
an undertone that that seeps through
it's a common thread that i notice there
are a lot of different conversations no
matter what it's about anytime that it's
about culture always brings up the fact
that there is a loss of connection to
the past that there is the collapse of
religion and grand narratives and
community and i wonder whether
the
introduction of technology
and
the
increase in our awareness
or our visib the visibility of other
people's specialness and their ability
to communicate information
has maybe made us feel like what we have
to say is less important that we realize
that there's so much noise that the
signal we thought that we had you know
our voice moving forward just wanting to
try and create a body of work that we're
genuinely proud of let's say or wanting
to raise a son or a daughter or have a
family in a particular be a member of a
community because the community perhaps
now is so large and has access to so
many more people that you see as being
so much more competent than you are with
so much more expertise
so what's the [ __ ] point like why
yeah what have i got to add what have i
got to say that's going to contribute to
this so if that's the case why do i just
try and win the game by the lowest
common denominator the lowest hanging
fruit that i can i'm going to use
audience capture i'm going to limitly
hijack the people that are around me i'm
going to be more manipulative i'm going
to just try and chase down to get much
more shallow senses of of success
because
what can i actually contribute that's of
any genuine value in a world with seven
billion people all of whom can talk to
each other
well i a completely different
circumstance uh technologically uh and
culturally it would be
so-called dark ages europe in which
there are monks producing illuminated
manuscripts
that uh almost no one in the rest of
population would be able to read
um and which may only be seen on
by a few pairs of eyes
but why do they do it
they do it because they are
they are curating celebrating and
transmitting
um
a culture of value and a virtue which
they believe in
partly because it has a moral purpose to
it
so i for instance i'm not saying it's
the same um but i've written a book
there's a huge amount of effort that
goes into that i'm normally prior to
that i'd be very much a social media
person on twitter well you could in the
course of five minutes become famous on
twitter and you can also five minutes
later be destroyed by twitter and never
heard from again except uh you know you
know there'll be an itv program a few
years time about whatever happened too
um so you you could rise and fall so
quickly but a book is a completely
different process involving loads of
people a long time editing showing it to
friends contacting experts so i think
it's partly about the nature of the
cultural production if you if you're on
twitter or instagram and that's where
you're trying to get noticed it's it's
actually easier uh but it won't have a
long-term effect and you won't be read
by generations to come whereas i always
think one reason why i still do books
and why i prefer actually i'm honest
writing for print newspapers that i do
for online because i have this fantasy
that the the
the product will still be available in
100 or 200 years time that it'll be
sitting in a in a library or an archive
somewhere and that um you know some
invading species or some future
telegenetic person will read it and find
it as fascinating as i do an illuminated
manuscript from the 12th century the
lindy effects a hell of a drug all the
way down
tim stanley ladies and gentlemen people
want to keep up to date with what you're
doing where should they go
oh they can go to
timothystanley.com.uk or just buy the
book buy the book it's it's very good
whatever happened to tradition history
belonging in the future of the west will
be linked in the show notes below tim
thank you so much what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace